emotional intelligence is the quality
that enables us to confront with
patience insight and imagination the
many problems that we face in our
effective relationship with ourselves
and with other people the term emotional
intelligence may sound odd we're used to
referring to intelligence just as a
general quality without on picking a
particular variety a person might
possess and therefore we don't tend to
highlight the value of a distort of
intelligence which currently does not
enjoy the prestige it should every sort
of intelligence signals and ability to
navigate well around a particular set of
challenges
mathematical linguistic technical
commercial when we say that someone is
clever but add that they've made a mess
of their personal lives or that they've
acquired a fortune but are restless and
sad or that they are powerful but
intolerant and unimaginative we're
pointing to a deficit in what deserves
to be called emotional intelligence in
social life we can feel the presence of
emotional intelligence in a sensitivity
to the moods of others and in a
readiness to grasp the surprising things
that may be going on for other people
beneath the surface emotional
intelligence recognizes a role for
interpretation and knows that for
example a fiery outburst might be a
disguised plea for help or that a long
political rant may be provoked by hunger
that concealed within a forceful
jolliness maybe a sorrow that has been
sentimentally disavowed in relation to
ourselves emotional intelligence shows
up in a skepticism around our emotions
especially those of love desire anger
Envy anxiety and professional ambition
the emotionally intelligent refused to
just trust their first impulses or the
inherent wisdom of their feelings they
know that hatred may mask love that
anger may be a cover
for sadness and that we are prone to
huge and costly inaccuracies around whom
we desire and what we really want
emotional intelligence is also what
distinguishes those who are crushed by
failure from those who know how to greet
the troubles of existence with a
melancholy and at points
darkly humorous resilience the
emotionally intelligent appreciate the
role of well handled pessimism within
the overall economy of a good life
emotional intelligence isn't an inborn
talent it's always the result of
Education specifically education in how
to interpret ourselves in where our
emotions arise from in our childhoods
influenced us and in how we might best
navigate our fears and our wishes in the
ideal society it would be routine to be
taught emotional intelligence from the
youngest age before we'd had the
opportunity to make too many mistakes
it's because we have until now not taken
emotional education seriously enough
that our species has grown ever more
technically adept while retaining the
level of wisdom of our earliest days
with catastrophic results we are now
evolved monkeys with nuclear weapons it
appears that the fate of civilization
depends on our capacity to master the
mechanisms of emotional education before
it's too late
an emotional education means something
far beyond just normal education as
we've conceived of it to date though it
should ideally include courses in every
year of school or college emotional
education is more than something that
should just take place in classrooms at
the hands of teachers and come to a halt
around the age of 21 the central vehicle
for the transfer of emotional
intelligence is culture from its highest
to its most popular level culture is the
field that can ritualize and
consistently promote the absorption of
emotional intelligence the lessons might
be embedded in a tragedy or a TV series
a pop song or a novel a work of
architecture or a YouTube film
we can envisage the entire apparatus of
culture as a subtle mechanism designed
to point us towards greater emotional
intelligence we will never progress as a
species and will indeed grow into ever
greater technologically armed menaces to
ourselves until we've accepted the
challenges and opportunities of properly
educating ourselves in emotional
intelligence our technical intelligence
is great of course it's led us to tame
nature and conquer this planet but a
wiser saner future for the human race
must depend on a capacity to master and
then seductively teach one another the
rudiments of emotional intelligence
while there is still time thank you for
watching liking and subscribing if you
want more why not visit us in person and
attend a class or take a look at our
shop at the link on your screen now